let's talk about the post office
everyone's favorite office so remember a
couple months ago there was this big
rumor that they were gonna get rid of
Saturday delivery and everyone went
berserk it was trending on Twitter for
days people were going crazy how am I
gonna get my junk mail on Saturdays I've
gotta have it well you're not the
government stepped in and they will be
delivering your mail on Saturday so the
idea would have saved the post office
two billion dollars but apparently
Congress wasn't into it and because they
control the post office even though they
don't fund the post office we're getting
Saturday mail back and we're not sure
how it's gonna be paid for you need your
Saturday mail don't you oh I stand by
the mailbox on Saturday I have nothing
else to do and I'm like is it coming is
it coming is it coming and I'm so
excited when it comes down and it's and
it's more credit card offers and people
offering to refinance my mortgage that I
just immediately rip up and then put
into the recycling bin and is there
anything you want more than that on a
Saturday no of course not I'm you know
I'm thrilled that Congress is finally
doing some good work is this completely
ridiculous I mean we were all okay with
it everyone joked about it work two
three days right but everyone sort of
was like all right and we don't know all
the public servants we know our mail
carrier yeah now you're messing with
extended family you're messing with a
friend of hers you know this is personal
this time you're coming after my friend
that I see every Saturday if I see that
look on their face like we may not have
Saturday's and that's gonna hurt my
friend now I'm mad at you
and it's as simple as that yeah we're
not as attached to all these other
wonderful public servants because we
just don't have this level of daily
interaction with them right but we
should feel this way when any of those
services are being cut away those are
all people they've got to go home and
explain their story to their families
too right but is this an example of like
just the overreach of government sort of
because the post office was willing to
do this you know what I mean they were
willing to try to save the money and
then and then the government's like no
no no we don't want you to save the
money this is the government we don't
have to save money I'm very confused
about this because you know the big
dialogue in Washington right now is
cutting everything so and here there was
actually an agency stepping forward and
and that's confusing to is like so
Congress can have overseeing the post
office but they don't fund them yeah so
what is that relationship and I'm just
curious I don't know what the
rationalization was by Congress about
this I'm guessing it had to do with
personnel or something like that but I
mean my understanding is that a lot of
money every month goes into pensions
future pensions and things like that and
if they if they didn't have to pay that
every month it actually be in the black
they'd be fine so the business I want to
cut those pensions for the guys that
Rick loves so that's what you're saying
no I'm just curious about like the math
here yeah the math is almost completely
the artificial math of the Republican
austerity push and we should never adopt
it ever and we should never even use
their considerations on that front
because all of it's just an artificial
trick to create chaos on on the other
guy's watch okay so I like where you
going with this so do you think all the
numbers when they throw all these crazy
numbers out to you all the time I mean I
was reading this article and there were
bajillion numbers do you think it's all
just nonsense and everyone manipulates
the figures either way to just push
their thing I mean who do we trust often
it's not what they say it's what they
leave out the fact that these numbers
exist does not mean that the austerity
measure was the only answer to it
yeah that's the big difference is there
they're posing these numbers like other
things can't be brought up to make the
solution work later they're saying they
are the only solution they just they're
using it just it makes our raw fear
occur yeah and panic moves and when you
panic move you don't think the situation
out very well
all right so even if there is some money
there and it's fear tactics and all that
Saturday mail I could let it go we sort
of started doing actually like it when I
used to like it growing up on Sundays
everything was shut down on Sundays yeah
I like that we stopped doing commerce
one day a week you know this hyper
consumerism in this country is I think
is a real problem and so I think the
having the weekend without mail just
from like a kind of mindfulness retreat
sense would be lovely yeah I don't want
anyone losing their job I don't want
anyone losing their benefits but the
world would continue spinning yeah and
what about the other guys just stepping
in
acts and ups and yeah that would then
wouldn't they pick up those other
privatization but yeah FedEx can ask
whatever they want yeah and they're not
regulated federally for Federal Express
they're not regulated they get that name
like the Fed itself dog head-tilt but
those kinds of things are certainly the
contradictions we're looking at more
deeply now yeah like you know instead of
like a letter costing what is it 46
cents right now is it 46 I think it's 46
$0.01 that went up 36 cents to for my
letter to go from here to across town or
military go from here to New York right
now there's no other service that
charges the same amount for that when
you're talking distance and and jet fuel
on all of that that confuses me a little
bit maybe Rick just back to your radical
plan to change the post office all right
but to think put me in charge of this
yeah you know it's just like the push to
make everything a privatized version of
it just means then they can there's
nothing regulating them that's why they
hate that the actual technical reason
most corporations don't believe in
government as government is a cop
watching the crook right and they just
want but what crook wants the copter
exactly don't forget bonobos comm is the
official outfitter of the Reuben report
they've got great new slim fit shirts
I've never felt sharper enter code TR RT
0 for 20% off your first purchase